[Music]
hello hello and welcome back to the
break group this is our clear C class
this is our daily live show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy news you
need to know coming up on the show today
nine more characters are joining the DCU
what is there room for that I don't know
sleepy Sneezy go for God happy grumpy
pimpy scrumpy and Superman and Gizmo uh
we also have some updates on secret
Invasion and it's not coming sooner than
we thought oh God uh and also we have
some updates on Star Wars movies
remember those oh God
franchise used to be movies yeah uh and
we'll be discussing whether Scotland is
still in the quantum room after all have
you seen Ant-Man I hope so uh I'm
Brandon Barrack who cares across the
table today we got koi Chandra rest and
ready for cocaine bear there's a reason
for this shirt oh Bear yeah
I thought you were just dressed and
ready for cocaine speaking of dressing
ready for Go game we got Jessica Clement
I'll take one eight ball please oh boy
she's responsible yeah yeah good good uh
stewards of of nerdum right now
my secret
[Applause]
just kidding kids out there watching
Flintstone vitamin three glasses of
water a day eight bowls of cereal a
healthy breakfast two Slim Fast shakes a
healthy choice dinner a Domino's hot and
ready pizza and the new Papa John's
parmesan crust pizza king that's how you
keep this body fit oh okay I like that
idea those aren't sponsors but they
could be we're open for sponsorships uh
we're also open for headlines oh
yes these are the hot headlines today
Marvel is known for its rewrites
reshoots and re-edits and it seems
quantumania is no exception oh it seems
that there was a version of the movie
where hope had two children what
hopefandine yes uh an Instagram post
over the weekend parents of a child
actor shared pictures from set showing
hope holding a baby in one arm uh and
her other around uh the young actor
Lucas Grant who had shot some seats for
the movie that I guess got cut out a
movie uh we were speculating about what
this could be from it seems like this is
like maybe what a like a probability
version of Hope from that probability
storm sequence in the movie maybe that
was longer or this could be like a hope
that uh Scott comes back to after being
trapped in the quantum realm or
something like a different potential I
don't know we're pretty sure all this
week we're going to be hearing about
different endings to this movie this is
such a big reflection
does it give a different vibe because
the whole point of the movie is like
getting more time with Cassie and then
to have these two others these two kids
they love their dads but they love them
but then maybe that could give way to
why Cassie was so mad during the movie
maybe there was already she already had
little siblings
she's okay well I guess I'm going to
prison
that makes the problem worse you have
this issue
all the time you go to the quantum realm
with him you have a whole adventure and
when you come back it's like oh no this
is a Rowdy where there's two other kids
now uh it creates like a whole new Rift
it'd be so interesting that it kept hope
out of the quantum realm for that reason
like because also the hair is different
like she's got her that was the mom I
think was that no no yeah totally
different hair she's dressed as like a
mom just a picture of her on a blue
screen like you know I thought she was
holding her children
yeah yeah
no no it's unrecognizable
but like that is on point that seems
like a different movie like yeah that's
such a like rewrites are usually like
there's a nudge this is like oh we are
family can I can I pause it pause it
please may I pause it please begging you
uh you know uh it makes me think that
maybe there was an element of Kang's uh
the the like power source that he needed
remember when when uh when Janet touches
it she sees all of the things that Kang
had done yeah I wonder if there was an
an element of wind like Scott and hope
touched it it projected different
futures for them and they were able to
see like perhaps that was some sort of
magic you know I mean there's all sorts
of like
you know marvel the MCU is all about
these threads these different
multiverses that go across or these
different branches on the same timeline
I wonder if maybe there there was more
of the the timeline branching involved
in in this movie before and then it
became more of the story of Janet and
Kang and what we ultimately saw in King
trying to escape so my thought is that
was probably a a scene from a potential
Branch timeline or something yeah I like
that it's seems like because I I did the
probability field was missing that it
was missing a family it was like here's
a million different versions of Scott
Lang here's one where he's Baskin
Robbins and I'm like okay Scott Lang
that wasn't a robber what about this guy
Lang that didn't work at Boston I think
there should there should have been a
Scotland they had gotten so famous from
being Ant-Man that he had radical
plastic surgery oh so there was like
there was like this Scotland there's
like it kind of feels like everything
everywhere all at once where it's like
yeah she had such different versions of
herself I wanted to see the like
extraordinary versions which would have
been that but maybe that would have
taken away from the plot of like it's
about Cassie
two babies but I also think that if they
included it at all like I wonder what
the script was that allowed for that big
of a pivot that would cause any
ramification that didn't get yeah like
it feels like if that happens the whole
rest of the movie has to change in the
last year version right because it needs
to be something that just like loops and
goes away well we it feels like every
couple of weeks we're still getting news
about like oh this was going to be a
Multiverse event yes right that one
seems to have the longest like we had
different plans for it we know so much
was cut from like four level Thunder and
yeah like whole Parts
yeah yeah so we'll we'll keep hearing
more and more about what didn't make it
for me did Kang conquer did he Butcher
and he butchered me oh my God uh and we
had Jeff loveness tweeting out modot's
butt this weekend you know what's what's
crazy is I heard one thing that was cut
from Thor 11 Thunder was a coherent
story okay Tommy get down off your
soapbox all right
is Paul running too much too much I've
got a lot of work John it's been fun if
they had another actor that was almost
casting oh yeah
I'm so mad at it Josh Josh Lucas running
around it was like there's a chance it
could have been me but if it was like
not the same Vibe but what if it was
Michael Shannon
it was a mean version of it were you
shocked this is totally side it's not in
the script sorry I'm going off book well
were you shocked to see Michael Shannon
get back into DC before he got his
Marvel yeah when's he gonna get picked
up by Marvel to be in a Marvel movie oh
I mean come on he could be a great
Galactus
I say you counter program
him is like a real Richard's like a
smile oh yeah I hate it would that be
creepy as him as like a happy man it's
so funny though that is the thing is
like he I mean it was Twas the night
that Christmas movie where he plays the
weed dealer yeah he is hilarious in
there bro the funnier nice get rearrange
that like frat letter the yeah I mean
he'd be a good Doom from that alone he's
also actually sorry Jessica no go he's
also a very talented improviser I was
gonna say I did improv for him and he
went
was like you guys are very funny but I
remember watching him smile and it was
scary as hell he said I said I hate you
I loved it I had a great time uh too
much work too much plastic surgery no
well speaking about these reshoots it
seems that secret Invasion will be
adding some of their own uh
cinematographer Evan Bolter most notably
the cinematographer on the most recent
episodes of The Last of Us love it seen
it cried every time uh he has allegedly
uh this Mr Bolta has been hired uh to
shoot these reshoots for secret evasion
which we thought was right around the
corner I don't know uh his Twitter bio
currently even reads Marvel hashtag TBA
like to be announced so he's doing
something for Marvel right now the rumor
is it's these reshoots for secret
Invasion we still don't have a release
date for something Invasion yeah they
said spring there's a look okay we know
what we said right sometime before June
21st
uh the rumor lately was May Tommy we had
hoped March just because there was there
hasn't been a series since She-Hulk
which was the summer we're starving for
it over here we only do two this year
which is one of the rumors yeah they
said they might cut down from like
because it was five at one point right
and then they they said they only
guaranteed or the two it would make
sense to kind of like first half second
half the year it yeah May would be like
you know leading up to Guardians build
that hype like Marvel likes to do they
like to have a show lead into a movie
and then maybe since that's November now
they do October for what's the uh the
other one we're definitely getting this
year not Echo because
yeah
summer was what they were saying for
that to back to back them yeah I don't
know I wonder sorry uh I know you were
just apologize I keep cutting Jessica
off today I gotta work I wasn't saying
anything uh I could see you I could
sense you I sense your power uh no I
feel like maybe this has to do with uh
movie releases and what is revealed in
those movie releases I mean it doesn't
make a ton of sense that Guardians is
going to be directly involved in the
secret Invasion however those worlds I
mean they're in space someone's in space
space is a big place Thomas Scrolls Cree
could be involved it's loose I still
think the career involved with something
involving Kang and Time rings and then
the Bangles and then Shang Chi's 10
rings so I'm wondering if the connection
to Guardians is gonna be something
involving the Korean squirrels that
would kind of work it's just the street
invasion is scroll based and it just
kind of seems like Marvel's not exactly
the type of Studio that's like we're
really we botched this we gotta we're
gonna do a we're gonna do a total
facelift on it and like we gotta we're
gonna spend weeks and weeks and months
and months of reshooting this entire
show from the beginning I mean that's
happened in other Studios we know but
like admit I mean like extensively
secret invasion is probably done right
right it could be as simple as they've
changed something in
additional photography sometimes is like
a day yeah yeah but it's also
interesting that they move the Marvels
and now this because I think those are
going to tie together right I think the
paranoia we get from Miss Marvel ending
with paranoia right that was that like
the world of hates and fears them they
finally said mutants and then I think
the Marvels is going to be dealing with
that to a bigger scale and secret
invasion is literally about paranoia
Thunderbolts is the Pinnacle of that
Thunderbolts is like can we trust Our
Heroes yeah maybe they're adding some
things to add to that conspiracy flavor
by the way the Marvels November 10th
hashtag Bechtel Birthday Bash Bonanza oh
we're gonna be celebrating I think I'm
gonna run out of whole theater and just
throw it no more that's gonna be amazing
I think I might why not I'd love to see
the Marvels on my birthday
I bet the theater's gonna be so
expensive that day though because it's
the Marvel you know what money is
nothing to a man like me by the way my
venmo is at Tommy Dash back told start
contributing now for the Bechtel
Birthday Bash Bonanza also they did a
poll for what's better for your body and
62 is a pizza
well all this all this Marvel
speculation you know there's a good
saying out there wise Manson once said
that when you when a Marvel door closes
a Star Wars door opens with a cool
futuristic noise with an elevator it's
the it's the paper coming out of the
envelope yeah
they used for the doors
perfect perfect well so now that we have
quantumania out in the world it's time
to get ready for a Mandalorian season
three baby which premieres next week
sorry I didn't mean to scream and in a
recent interview John faprow said that
he has already written season four which
is a very smart thing to do say you got
the next season already written baby
right when those when those grogu checks
start being cashed once the girl group
starts aging up I you got it you gotta
bring something else in you know having
a new baby that's insane that you say
that uh because I have a major
announcement I've already written season
three of the Mandalorian Wookie leaks
I've already written no you've already
written it I haven't seen any episodes
but it has been written you're assuming
I'm just hoping uh and I guess the way
Brandon if you'd like to just take it
away and announcement well yeah so what
we're gonna do break room is now gonna
be the after show home here on new
rockstars we've been covering the last
of us uh here on in the break room on
Sundays with a little after show so
Wookie leaks will be replacing break
room episodes on Wednesdays during the
Mandalorian so during the the Run of
Mandalorian on Wednesday's break room
will become Wikileaks I'm so excited
they will be put into a chamber and
cloned into into Wikileaks and that
means you Wookie freaks better be ready
because we're not just bringing me back
that's right we're bringing back Pretty
Ricky Voss wow
kiss me through the phone uh and uh now
we are yeah we're bringing black Voss
bringing back me and we're gonna have
some special guests or guests or a guest
I don't know put you this way we've made
some calls to Harrison Ford but he's not
flying planes right now
he'll ride but he won't pilot him
anymore get off my plate get off my
Wookie leaks well we're very excited to
have what Gilly's coming back we're
super excited for Mandalorian season
three and it seems like we're going to
be getting some news about the future of
cinematic forays into the Star Wars
Universe uh it was announced that Disney
would put will be sharing their upcoming
plans in April at Star Wars celebration
in London better
we assumed they would be sharing stuff
but I saw something interesting I don't
know is this a scoop it's my it's it's a
concern it's a rumor it's it's all three
things okay this is a heavy rumor scoop
it is uh
Mike should be here very deep cut I know
but those uh during this announcement
there was also a sentence that worries
me saying that there would not be you
should come this year because there will
of course not be a celebration in 2024.
whoa so I wonder is if they announce
movies and they don't want to share
anything until they're ready with them
in 2025 and they're literally taking a
pause
do we think at Celebration they're like
hey Kathleen Kennedy stepping aside Papa
foggy's coming
oh like they'll bring feige over to the
Star Wars sign I don't know I don't know
that because someone will step down and
someone takes spot those are just the
names that come to mind and that they're
going to take a year to reassess this
movie stuff no celebration is 24. are
you going to London I hope to okay you
don't think they'll bring in I went to
the last one in London it was lovely
sorry Fabro to take over Star Wars photo
like that would be incredible but I
don't know if he wants to yeah I think
he likes being able to like play do Star
Wars yeah and then like oh if I want to
go direct another movie I can go do that
like the reason I reflex spiky spiky so
much is that I don't think anyone else
can have the Panache of the enjoyment of
it he seems to love it and like everyone
else in that position seems to be like
like how many people they interview for
DC like we stop people being like yeah
I'm rumored and they got like older like
a president yes I don't know if that's
gonna be anything that anyone wants I
agree yeah uh it would be interesting if
they do plan to put celebration on hold
for next year because they only do d23
every other year that's what I heard and
that would put it on a weird like
scheduled for like the Olympics now uh
so I don't know it was intriguing
because I could see them being like
we're gonna do movies and focus on that
we need a year to recalibrate yeah I was
looking forward to a 24 celebration in
Anaheim you know it's an easier one
we'll see I'm sure the fans will still
22 was like one of my favorite cons ever
that celebrations that was really fun
Eric and I had a blast I still have my
cereals well we went to 23 together
though Brandon 223 we always have those
that will always have we'll always have
that 20 minutes of Avatar uh that's
funny enough speaking of Avatar that you
can't fight don't bet against big Jimbo
or by big Jimbo I mean James Cameron
okay Avatar wave water has become the
third highest grossing movie of all this
man sitting at
2.433 billion dollars and Counting every
day every day another a-lister makes
that their third movie of the week uh
Avatar wave water has of course eclipsed
Cameron's first injury on the list
Titanic if you're familiar with that
joint uh and it's still sitting above
where uh sorry still sitting above way
of water on that list is Avengers end
game still up there and of course the
first avatar I do appreciate these two
theaters right now and see both Titanic
and the second avatar and you can
support either the third or fourth
biggest movie he just he would he you
know James Cameron he goes into stasis
he goes away hibernates is of course
working very hard and when he comes back
he's got a big old scary band for us did
you guys have I don't know if you've
seen it as much in your comments but
like people being like I'm mad at the
Ant-Man CGI because of avatars and then
I'm like yes but that took 10 years yeah
like there's an interesting feeling
honestly Corey watching Avatar wear
water insane movie Crazy visuals don't
remember anyone's name but they're
during some of those battle Secrets I
was like man this looks like it's
incredible and I wish they had a lot of
Marvel movies like had this amount of
patience and Care yeah
years to make that move Corky
he initially was like it's got to be the
third biggest of all time and then like
a few months ago they're like maybe
Sixth and now it's third he's like
correct correct okay we'll get four more
of them three more of them coming uh
can't wait very shortly uh thank you to
our super Chatters out there ate some
super chats coming in uh Quinton pointed
out this has been very interesting for
who could take over Star Wars the Return
of George confirms yeah George Lucas
will never come back I'm so mad at all
of you you were so mean to him yeah
we're coming back and getting loved can
you imagine if George sees the prequels
finally getting their love shows up at
Celebration
his wife is even like don't do it that
shows up beardless no one recognizes it
announces it comes in there what's who's
this man I'm the new CEO George Lucas
you're still wearing the same
what are the names of my characters that
make you go to a minion release beard
listen if you could pay up paella uh
Corey can't really Point uh excited for
Bechtel Birthday Bash Bonanza oh yeah uh
mj2997 saying they're probably in
reference to our research for secret
evasion suggesting maybe they're putting
Harrison Ford
if they're going through and wiping uh
Ritz and the other president
uh Preston Jones trash Panda for trash
play Trash plates the signature dish of
Rochester New York oh okay
it's not it's so good and then Nick
Alexander asking do you think phase four
to six will be a complete King loop from
baby Kang to he who remains I mean I've
got an interesting idea of the ending of
the movie kind of tying into what's to
come like are we doing spoilers at this
point yeah uh yeah if you haven't seen
amen in the west quantumania uh put this
on pause the Banner's up boys we're
talking spoilers we assume you saw the
movie at this point if not come back to
us it'd be interesting if the
post-credits scene was in reference to
something that happened in Kang Dynasty
it'd be really interesting if we find
that like that event they were referred
to the post-creditsy with the three of
them it'd be fun if they were like
actually not talking about the entire
Ant-Man movie we just saw and they were
like stuff stuff didn't real they're
touching the Multiverse but it's like
actually
it'd be interesting if we see uh this
out of sequence like I keep saying that
some of the Marvel films in phase four I
don't think take place chronologically
like when we think like how many times
we had a chart like I think that maybe
Kang is manipulating time in a broader
way and so like when you line up phase
four it'd be fun if they Fast and
Furious it and Tokyo Drift actually
isn't the third one right it's later
because yeah so it'd be fun if Kang
isn't the Kang we met in Ant-Man first I
strangle the person that came up with
that idea especially as the bird because
remember that you talked about this that
there was like someone at Marvel that
has to keep track of the timeline but
like it's a bunch of people to team but
it's also like that poor person's like
you guys have made my job
people are jumping well as we have our
spoilers uh out of the box here let's
get into our main discussion today we're
talking about like the that probability
storm that we saw in the film and kind
of the end of the film right
and we were positing the idea we talked
about this in the office that the idea
that this Scott at the end of the movie
were hearing his voice over who's he
talking to it's very weird it's very
like personal in his head uh but the
idea that maybe that Scott that came out
wasn't the same Scott that went in okay
yeah one of those probability storm
Scots is the ones that got out uh and
now he's in like a weird space like
basically this is not 616 Scott this is
like another Sky I like that right uh
and producer John found some crazy
evidence to support this idea okay and
kind of freaked down and had a moment uh
went a little crazy okay so we get this
Welcome Back Cotter song at the
beginning of the movie uh setting the
stage right and one of the lyrics that's
in this song and the very first line of
this song Right is quote welcome back
your dreams were your ticket out okay
your dreams were your ticket out and
what did we learn about dreams uh this
this last year in 2022 Multiverse dreams
are not just little made-up things of
your a brain defragmenting the day and
having a fun time while you're asleep no
they review into a world of your variant
and another Multiverse
okay okay so if your dreams are your
ticket out that means your variants are
the way that you can get out okay you
can swap places with three more dreams
you can dream walk a little bit in your
face all right two-faced Face Off Face
Off now Scott seems really uncomfortable
when he gets back right he's saying
things like who said Life had has to
make sense right he's saying all this
kind of insane stuff like maybe stop
asking so many questions stop
overthinking it right yeah and it's and
like this guy's like it sounds like he's
not gonna go tell anyone what just
happened yeah and at dinner he was like
uh it seemed very like this is in here
yeah and like we were saying who would
even call right because like Cap's kind
of gone I guess he maybe still has like
Sam Wilson's number and the book that I
read that I know is not really can I did
a video on this he was how did he get
from point A to Germany to fight
alongside Captain America it was through
Sam Wilson so Sam wilsonham are actually
friends underneath and we just haven't
seen it yet like he might call Sam
Wilson and be like hey just so you're
aware
there was this guy down there I think I
killed him but we're cool because even
at the end of the movie he's like is he
dead he's dead right he's totally I
gotta worry about that uh and we know
Janet had like a hard time face didn't
want to tell anybody about it right and
now like Scott doesn't want to maybe and
maybe that's because it's not our Scott
right it's a different Scott who's like
I'm just happy to be here and I'm not
gonna I won't Rock the Boat yeah I like
the idea that it still could be like if
it was a probability Scott it's still
Scott genuinely right like how Gamora
but more even more so because this is a
probability it's a branch so it is it is
Scott it's just not the Scott but it's
the sky more cowardly than this guy
trapped in the quantum realm right
exactly I thought that's how the film
was gonna go right and it might be a fun
reveal that he is this God is it's not
our Scott we we talked about this on
inside Marvel so technically could the
probabilities of Scott be able to to
touch other people because we saw that
hope and him were able to touch and grab
hands right but hope I assume wasn't
allowed to touch him because he was just
a figment he was a probability oh the
other ones yeah so he was able to climb
them that's what I but it was him but it
was him right but hope wasn't so him
outside of the world and him interacting
with people did that make it so the
probabilities are able to become Seattle
the storm was the only place that that
could have the multiplicity thing happen
so would they even exist or would they
cease to exist out of that storm that's
exactly what I was thinking okay you're
thinking physically yeah yeah same thing
probabilities
but keep going I like the idea there was
also in that inside Marvel that we think
like the Quan this probability field
might only exist within the quantum run
right so if he did get out he could
still get out and be effect not
fictional non-fictional and it would be
a place that would only exist in that
time Vortex where the Multiverse engine
has to exist because it theoretically
small and large uh pin particles were
around it right so it's constantly
Contracting and expanding which is why
it was in that state of flux so if
you've got a Multiverse engine mixed
with a state of flux that's causing
stuff to expand and contract rapidly
that would make sense that it would be
the one place where multiplicity could
effectively happen right if if time is
literally surging and every decision you
make would cause a Schism that is some
Logic for that to exist but the question
would be is outside of that do things
survive because theoretically outside of
that orb of possibility nothing should
be able to survive okay right I'm just
gonna add this one one more little thing
and we'll get back to the script okay so
what if because we also don't know
whether or not we were talking about
whether or not magic exists within the
quantum realm because we haven't seen it
yet and we saw how uh she did it and
wanted it in Multiverse Madness to
Fantastic she was able to unravel him
and then we see him unraveling in the
quantum realm probability field what if
there is an essence of uh like not
um not Doctor Strange Magic but chaos
chaos magic with the quantum realm so if
that came to be she was able to bring
her sons into an existence into the real
world so maybe it's like he can leave
the quantum realm Thor brought up that
man magic is just science we can't
explain yet
what if you've got we talked about it
briefly the uh the high evolutionary
doing his little Wanda float yeah
dark magic is explained more
scientifically with the evolutionary and
all that comes back to this Quantum
realm yeah
and he's real dark magic exists in
between the the Multiverse the planes it
is the what fills in with dark energy
and that's what I think it comes from
the dark dimension right and when you
are dreamwalking you're using Dark
Energy
in between two universes and that's why
they call it you keep talking about the
afterlife we keep talking about the veil
we keep talking about like you know
although there's been so much afterlife
in phase four yeah there's been and
we've we've touched on one degree we've
touched on the the thinness of the
planes between reality I still think
there's going to be something about gods
in the afterlife and all that come to
play it'd be fun if it was science okay
so I would I assumed I assumed in a
stupid way I think it's just really fun
if limbo was actually the probability
filled within the quantum realm and
that's is a state of hell and that's one
of the stages of hell
um
and I still think the Fantastic Four is
going to be stuck somewhere they're
stuck somewhere just because they're
working they're stuck somewhere I'm hung
up on it I'm hung up on it sorry that
was that's all very valid parts of this
conversation some of the other thoughts
we had with this this guy maybe not
being our Scott right he gets he gets
Cassie's birthday wrong and he's like oh
I'm just making up for all the bridges I
miss but what if he thought it was her
birthday right
I had no idea and I'm just panicking
also like he has to wear the bite of
cake and he's like oh that's awful right
yeah it could be because Greg turkey's
character is a horse he established he's
not good at decorating cakes birthday
wrong but also maybe not but like I will
say at Baskin-Robbins you're not
building the cake you're just decorating
the cake the cake comes already built
yeah so and he tastes the cake he's like
oh this is terrible what if like he's
from a world where cake tastes different
and Cake in our world tastes gross to
him oh because he's from a dementia
where cake tastes like steak and he
thinks it tastes like cake tastes like
steak I love that we wanted Ant-Man to
have an ending with like this this
weight so now we're like yeah we're like
but it does maybe it did but he won't
know until Ant-Man Cassie's mom and
stepdad are not at this party at the
movie of course Bobby Cannon Valley they
had a difference where's David the small
chick where's David
where's T.I and um
the biggest misstep for me was my
opinion not explaining to Paul Rudd what
happened in the five years and then just
giving a summaries of all the Marvel
shows right yes can you imagine him just
reciting what happened on She-Hulk and I
wonder if I wonder if Michael Pena was
like I'll do it for five million dollars
or I'm not coming back and they were
like all right sorry they're going to
the quantum realm yeah uh great uh uh
Brunswick boy 86 asking what if the same
what if it's the same amp family but
they came out of the quantum realm in a
different Multiverse saying like they
didn't land at 616. they came like when
that door closes and it reopens is that
a different Castle
because there's got to be some
multiverses that are so so close
uh Rick and Morty literally they died in
one timeline they go to another timeline
if they just went to a timeline where
they're already dead or just missing
they could be like oh we're back yeah
for the writers too the Rick and Morty
writers who did this would it make more
sense
me and Brandon not saying that he didn't
work on any other season we started
looking at the episodes Jeff loveness
wrote for Rick and Morty and it was a
lot of the fourth and fifth season in
sixth season right uh not in the first
two where they really get into them
while they were doing crazy stuff yeah
he's credited as like the writer for
episodes and because they pick one Rider
to be the writer but every writer is
like I don't know when he started it on
the show
um and then GSU Eagle 117 asking can we
possibly get Modoc back if and somehow
repair him yeah I mean he's coming back
yeah there will be modak again in the
MCU yes uh especially with a character
who died once and dying twice
what is that is it a toe a Tommy
organism designed only for cuddling
and then of course like who's who's
Scott talking to at the end it's so
weird is he talking to us is he aware of
us is every character in the MCU gotta
become break the fourth wall at some
point there's gonna be some there's
going to be some like magical creature
doing this to his brain like uh like
Mojo oh yeah it's Mojo night and please
stop suggesting that I play at least
disgusting looking everyone that says
that to me hurts my feelings
is that a lot of people online anyway uh
you know like the way Wanda had all the
citizens of uh West View yeah under her
uh her thing there's gonna be someone
doing that to Scott's brain he's gonna
be sitting in a weird yeah he's being
happy in a very uh dumb way do we oh
this has nothing to do I'm so sorry
there's nothing to do wow right thanks
for listening uh
beep it would make him so cry
um in a dumb way if we do believe that
breaking the fourth wall does have
something to do with anything even if it
is a mutant Gene and it we do have
Deadpool doing it we do have uh She-Hulk
doing it uh and then we do have him
doing it would that be a uh we have
Scott doing it is it because Scott went
into the quantum realm where possibly
yeah
in the comics like long exposure to pin
particles eventually affects your body
the Lang family has a predisposition to
like creating their own internal pin
particles which is why Cassie gets kind
of like Powers is there anyone else in
the MCU today that has broken the fourth
wall as directly as a voiceover because
I can't think of a lot of voices they do
it in Iron Man 3 but it's a it's a
cop-out it's a trick uh he's talking to
Bruce at the you know Tony's talking to
Bruce at the end yeah but you think he's
talking to you at the beginning of the
movie yeah
I think it's just those two I don't
think we've had a a narration like this
yeah and then well coordinates the they
never ages but again he's telling the
story to the kids at the end I mean want
or not want to yeah She-Hulk but she
also the fourth yeah
Wanda looks at the camera on Multiverse
of Madness she does look at the camera
oh that's insinuating that she does see
us at one point
yeah to me that implied we're a
Multiverse and I maintain the shield
thing like it would have been really
interesting if they implied that we were
her other so like Hulk has the other guy
his rage it'd be fun if she has like a
presentational side so we're the other
guy for her but I'm wondering if they're
ever going to have any uh you know
allowance of what this fourth wall
breakers of that man because it's a fun
thing but there's got to be a reason
yeah there's got to be a reason uh and
you know what hey Brandon yeah I I've
been meaning to ask you okay I I really
want to get some Ant-Man quantumania
American oh yeah but times are tough for
me my car breaks down once a week oh
that's strong and uh the repairs have
never been cheap and I've got a movie
theater to run out yeah I can't pay full
price for quantumania
is it coming up well Tommy if you're
looking to score some quantities
quantumania merch on a discount baby
right now all of our quantumania merch
is on sale starting today sorry today
that's right at nerd riot.trap you get
all of our quantumania merch uh 15 off
at nerd riot.shop uh including this
lovely Kang shirt and a lot of our other
ant manager there's a wash shirt there's
more Kang shirts there's a Quantum Thief
that I really tickles my fancy really
good uh it's it's all 50 off to the end
of the month at nerd riot.shop if you're
an ant Stan or a king Man Dan we've got
you covered baby uh and tomorrow
Wednesday February 22nd oh boy the first
two items of our Mandalorian season
three line will be available I know
what's happening to me
it's a preview baby
this is the balance shirt we're gonna
have this shirt available on the site
this will be the other one in our
collection that first rolls out this is
like the Bounty Hunter I'll take 10.
they have this like fun like best car
inside exactly like that as a baby yeah
interesting looking baby that's what we
always say interesting
uh uh so you can grab it starting
tomorrow and if you purchase any manual
any shirt from the man jewelry
collection and get the shout out add-on
for a few extra bucks your name and a
little message will be displayed on our
Wikileaks after show it might even get
right aloud by Tommy bechtold or Eric
Pretty Ricky Voss you mean reading
things like Pretty Ricky Cory kendrilli
says I think Fantastic Four will be
stuck in the negative Zone yes just like
that or free girl Tommy Husby says you
need to portray John Madden twitch I say
boom
I like to stick a goose and a duck and a
turkey all together and make a bow
that's Thanksgiving tough actington
acting all right there was his Madden 15
30.
if you order that shirt now if you
ordered one of the Mandalorian shorts
and they you choose that shout out
option we'll be saving all the shout
outs for these first two shirts for the
first episode of WikiLeaks so get those
orders in now have the shirt for the
premiere and get your name on the first
Wookie leaks the entire collection will
drop when Mandalorian drops so keep your
eyes peeled for more new shirts check
out that merch sale for the Ant-Man and
wasp quantumania merch head to nerd
riot.shop check out all the merch
options and support new rock stars yeah
buy buy the chat option if you get the
shout outs I'll read as many I don't
care if I die Tommy will just read them
all buy a thousand shirts I'll read a
thousand names uh Tyler just read them
all now for our second discussion today
I'm glad you're here because we're gonna
get DC dirty baby we know James Gunn
loves sharing some DC news over Twitter
and Instagram so this is our social
media gun day yeah I'm still not sold on
that name yeah we're trying to work how
to use oh I was thinking of Watergate
I think it's like update it's like a gun
date
like I think we should call it the gun
club I don't know I'm not I'm not
comfortable with that either and this
thing in this climate uh well in front
of my salad yeah so so James Gunn loves
to say stuff on Twitter maybe too much
stuff on Twitter I don't know uh one of
the things he talked about was casting
news will be coming in the next six
months I'm not gunning for an update oh
wow
gun in your mouth
what about that gunshot wounds no stop
gunning for an update uh James Gunn also
shared that Creature Commandos and
Superman Legacy were both in development
before him and saffron were hired as the
heads of DC Studios we know gun's been
working on that Superman script for a
while and
he that gun is quote far end quote into
writing the Legacy script uh for
Superman Legacy saying he was hired over
six months to go to work on that you
brought some news to a gunfight shotgun
this I think two things happened with
that bit Yeah I think that they wanted
to remember we heard a lot about Hamada
not one in Camelback and they wanted a
new Superman yeah I think they probably
had an outline already percolating like
they were grooving with that right and
then Gunn came to them with his pitch
and then as that developed they were
like oh we also we need you know want to
be president we could use a I gotta run
this and then it turned into the
conversation and it might have been
because of his idea of Superman so I
firmly believe that's true but I think
that Superman might have led to gun
being hired more than we thought they
probably loved it yeah yeah
and then also James Gunn in a response
to a fan asking if Wonder Woman has a
future in his plans and if she will be
abandoned for a long time gun replied
yes no what if it is a no not abandoned
for a long time but long time uh who
knows some might consider three years to
be a long time I do yeah I consider six
months we know we're getting this like
prequel in chapter one I think she shows
up at the end of that yeah I think we'll
see so like baby is it like baby Anakin
and randomizer we're gonna see a young
Wonder Woman go wizard I think it'll be
interesting if they do what like flash
could do which is land with a new Batman
because Batman we know has to be cast
soon Superman has be cast soon right
they could use movies to announce their
characters in a way that Marvel's never
done like Marvel has post credit scenes
but they're starting a new universe
while using some of their old I would
love if the the mascara show ended with
like you see a familiar landscape maybe
battles have been you know born and then
you see someone walk across it into a
new Wonder Woman Like You can use the
setting as the origin what if what if
it's a doctor and he's like one more
push one more push
and he's holding the baby and then all
of a sudden he starts confessing things
because the umbilical code is the
original lasso of truth
it's wrapped around
I'm cheating on my wife also yeah why is
it wrapped around.com
I don't know maybe yeah maybe she was
wiling out I don't know a clay one Roman
origin where she's like the the daughter
of Zeus but like she's of clay like I
want them to end with like maybe a
molding and forming I like that I just
want her to be on the island and be like
what are we some kind of Wonder Woman oh
my God perfect perfect I just wanted to
be happy
perfect I love that idea uh and also
James after two different types of DC
heroes we like to see in guns DCU lists
were tagged so different Outlets made
these like list of Heroes that they want
to see James got put in James Gunn
responded to each list saying that one
of them had four out of eight right and
another one had five out of ten uh of
the heroes right on these two respective
lists the only hero that appeared on
both lists both lists was Nightwing uh
so for fear of having fans triangulate
who the heroes would be gun said he
wouldn't continue to share takes on this
but of course we can go through the
options and figure it out and then
Freeze Frame and let's see how right we
are yeah yeah we're gonna do exactly
what James good does not want us to do
yeah look at the Whiteboard Evan Evan
we were not allowed to help Evan bring
out the White House
close up on Evan please
look at him how cute he is so if my
frantic I'm sorry my frantic description
wasn't clear okay there were two lists
of Heroes that got tweeted at James Gunn
this is list one right here and this is
list two uh-huh this was four out of
eight and this was five out of ten okay
we see Nightwing on both so if you
eliminate Nightwing you're insane yep
we're each gonna eliminate two John
who's the two Green Lanterns Hal Jordan
and yeah uh Jon Stewart Kyle no come on
he's the fun one he's the fun one that
was gonna be my saying if you're ruining
myself can I un block him I can save him
now
okay so he's safe
by the power of Raynor okay uh I'm gonna
take away
you know I just don't I just don't see
Arsenal happening sorry right it reminds
I know who Arsenal is of course but if
some of our fans at home don't know
Arsenal as well uh I mean the the most
famous storyline involved him oding yeah
okay I don't see that happening okay
that's the favorite he's one of my green
arrows boys he's like kind of like the
robin guy that's why it was so traumatic
well speaking of robins are you just
keeping what's happening okay organized
oh I see I was like thank you I thought
it was safe up there thank you thanks
John important moment look here's the
deal folks we're getting Nightwing
obviously that Wing's gonna happen get
Jason Todd out of here
uh no I won't I won't save Jason time
but I'm tempted to well then I similarly
we know our Superman story of course is
going to be a young Superman story so
why would his son Jonathan hit Superman
okay be involved okay interesting
interesting
Jessica what do you say
um
I'm gonna get rid of John constant no oh
how could you whoa how could you because
keanu's playing him in a hello okay okay
this is getting tough right uh I want to
focus on this group because we're gonna
have four total on this group okay okay
we can't touch
my boy it's probably not happening but I
can dream I think static has got to
happen people are high on static yeah
uh Nightwing we know it's happening
these two I'm real iffy on Tara
manipulates the earth
I don't see you I don't need it I don't
see it I agree with you we don't need it
yeah bye Tara bye yeah well
yeah this is my turn again
no I think it's my turquoise turn Okay
uh
uh I think it's gonna be the villain of
the first Superman movie I think is
gonna be the villain because they're
bringing in Damian Wayne I think that's
who friends playing I think it's who
Jason Momo wants to play this is a
beloved character this is almost implied
this if they don't do it they're foolish
so Vixen
so this we think is our group too we're
thinking this is our group two right
here yeah so let's focus on group one
baby all right I'm gonna take Zatanna
off I know we have reasons why but I
think because they canceled recently the
plans for the Zatanna project she's just
further down the line I mean that
doesn't mean never right right this
means not just not not in this immediate
time not in these immediate times I know
uh okay Jessica who do you want to get
rid of um that's how I feel about the
court of owls
um I just don't it's too big to get into
right now do we only have one more to
get rid of yeah I think so wow no yes
yeah total you don't have to choose mine
no I I agree with you Jessica because if
if we're going by the Mr Freeze rule of
uh what's happening in the mountain do
you think Matt Reeves is gonna do court
before James Gunn does I think he might
absolutely because we thought he would
we're gonna see it in the Batman and
they playing we already saw it in the
Harley Quinn show and it was great they
play it's a really corrupt Gotham in
Matt Reeves that would allow for that to
be an underbelly and with the penguin
show you could play the long game which
I think would be genius yeah my only
concern is that the Damian Wayne Batman
versus uh versus Robin movie the
animated film is very owl based so if
they want to do certain Damian Wayne
stories I think Rochelle ghoul is
implied but I wonder if people will
associate that so much Liam Neeson yeah
so they might have to court of owls by
way of not Lazarus pitten yeah well if
you got rid of braini which one Brainiac
are the court of owls between the two I
would get rid of the court of owls
because I feel like Brainiac is the best
Deathstroke is is coming I feel like
Deathstroke is such a like Deadpool's
real popular right uh and I feel like
there's never really there's never been
a Deathstroke that's like to scale like
Deathstroke's such a big villain and
they always underwrite him like he's
always like I'm the big bad then it's
like oh my ankle I feel like James gun
is the kind of nerd that wants to get
Justice for characters so I feel like
Deathstroke is one that needs Justice
okay so I'd say between the two I'm
saying else quarter I mean I personally
would think Lobo really I think lobo's
like a waste
we don't need it people don't really say
they want you know don't save see I
think I'm saving the course okay and I'm
getting I'm saving logo
snakes are high all right then you got
to get rid of someone all right it can't
be the court and it can't be Lobo so you
gotta get rid of one of these four
Brainiac I hate those words who's your
Superman villain yeah the court of owls
I guess no Superman versus the court of
owls a bunch of Rich guys as long as
they can get them in a dark room and
you're fine
all right there's Kryptonite everywhere
nocturnal Sun's down what are you gonna
do lock lock in on this lock it in take
that James gun we figured out your your
evil scheme we figured it out all right
I feel okay he's like one is right I go
again we gotta do it he says like uh
prices our prices right well you can't
say one is right because we know
Nightwing is so it's like you got it so
yeah I know we said nine new people this
is technically only eight because oh
that's true but if you come back if you
get Nightwing off a list you gotta take
them off both and I think Nightwing has
got it yeah I I think that the math is a
little fuzzy because Court of owls is uh
more than one person also I feel like
that girl really snuck in here just
snuck in yeah I'm a little upset about
that would have been a lesser I think
Cassandra Kane has to show up eventually
actually whether or not she's bad girl
or not I think the bat family needs more
women and and Batgirl is more unique of
a bat person than most like she's got a
different backstory she's got a rich
character in her own so she's the most
spin-offable I think and that that's
gonna be really important that said I do
worry about a lack of I don't know the
last movie we took off well I don't know
about martial it started down this is
already done if not Deathstroke could we
think Frank Grill is playing do you guys
see that thing I shared oh about Frank
yeah he posted on his own story that
he's changing teams he's changing teams
so I feel this truck would be a good
I've got one word for you oh boy oh oh
no don't write that word oh that's okay
oh okay Frank Grillo is Mr mixopolittlex
and it's not even like a CGI character
it's just make him tiny and he's like
hey
I'm gonna mess you up
backwards
why are you making me look at that
all right beautiful Superman one mix up
playlist we figured it out James we
figured it out James uh it has the live
chat you've got Brita saying Jimmy guns
Jimmy Dome or Jimmy Gates mandatory gun
is a good one
oh I was right there I don't like the
the terminal my Apple watch just took up
Jimmy John's because we said Jimmy what
about gunshots
the say of the gun for his tweets the
tweeted I don't know I don't know I
don't know uh Russell Russo games also
pointing out quantumania doesn't mention
his podcast thank you uh and Miss Marvel
doesn't mention his book Rogers the
Musical shows Ant-Man at the Battle of
New York separate timelines questions
also doing the heavy lifting I thought
the Ant-Man thing for separate timelines
but I hadn't connected it to all of the
Ant-Man stuff that would then spell it
the other way that's interesting yeah
supposedly the book look out for the
little guy who is hitting bookshelves in
September a long way up from this movie
they're like wait what is this foreign
is one of my favorite Parts is I'm like
yeah we can go to the uh we can go to
the podcast we can go to the movies we
can go to television series give us the
books and force us have to force us to
have to go and read the books to know
what's Canon again that's why I like gun
announcing it via Comics because like
the people that read the board way ahead
like everywhere no I tried to I tried to
get Supergirl World of Tomorrow so not
everywhere you can't get it anywhere
close come on direct your local library
let's have great comic book comic book
collections folks check out your local
life if you have a utility bill you can
literally get a digital library card and
rent comic books digitally for free
steal my power we're so lucky to have
you from libraries
uh Dexter Mayo asking how long were the
one were the Pim Lang fan
wants him around because five years felt
like five hours for Scott did they come
back to a different year I mean this is
I think time is just so weird there it's
different for different people there was
a lot of dialogue saying the reason they
couldn't see the life was because they
were lower than you could imagine and
lower than you could see I'm wondering
if that was a space out of time because
I think the ants landed higher
dilation yeah like time spread
differently for them but we also don't
know what time I thought they went
through something that was an expansion
field
the ants fell through like there were
different portals and they felt the
report there was a timing yeah they had
like a time dilation spot but they were
also bigger right because Scott shrunk
down past right in the ants didn't yet
and they kind of like went off to the
side as they were bigger
um and then at the end of the movie I
thought they were gonna do something
clever with like the dog baby and like
those moments I was like is it another
world I was one for like three seconds I
thought maybe he was in the place we see
in Guardians oh yeah I was like the
things aren't human but like it seems
like it's normal but if he wasn't from
there he wouldn't know he wouldn't know
he wouldn't no uh
um there was another thing I saw oh Al
Sweden had asked any thoughts about the
creature that split into two and
attacked Janet Van Dyne well we had an
interesting theory was it you well yeah
I think it was maybe John or Zach I
forget who but the idea that uh all of
that was manufactured by Kang like he
released that little creature to like
save Janet to get on her good side
there's apparently a line that says
Nathaniel Richards like she refers to as
Nathaniel that they cut so it'd be
really interesting
I'm wondering if there was more time
with them that would have allowed for
sure
that just lands in the quantum realm
we'll have to fight those hordes off so
they probably kill so many people this
is how we get ants yeah well lots more
we're going to learn about this phrasing
a lot before we're going to learn about
this movie as the week goes on and the
weeks go on and on uh so keep your eyes
peeled for that we'll cover any new news
we get about Ant-Man and was quantumania
right here on new rockstars thank you
all for tuning in today be sure to check
out nerd riot.shop uh Ant-Man merch on
the sale uh through the rest of the
month bad batch reviews coming out
tomorrow
Mandalorian shirts man DeLorean sure
write that shop yeah discount the bad
batch uh be sure to check out that we've
got lots of more Ant-Man videos in the
channel this week lots to discuss about
the movie uh so be sure to check those
out and tune in to tomorrow same time
right here on your favorite uh YouTube
channel thank you for joining the break
room today thank you koi for being here
Tommy Jessica myself we hope you all
have a great rest of your Tuesdays late
Escape we'll see you next time right
here in the break room bye rubies
farewell
[Music]